hi this is writer director Michael
Matteo Rossi and basically I just want
to tell you why it shows the black magic
for my first feature misogynist I'm sure
that you've heard a lot of stuff
comparisons how does it relate to say a
higher grade camera like the red and you
know the Alexa and all of that and
understanding that we were on a limited
budget the thing that appealed to me the
most at first about the black magic was
the affordability of it it was you could
buy it just right out it was small it
was dynamic it was sturdy you know we we
shot on a super 35 sensor and the wide
dynamic range of it was incredible so
you know for any kind of first-time
directors cinematographers all of that
if you really want to get your hands on
something I think that's the black magic
is something that really is not going to
kill your wallet first of all it's going
to look amazing um the last feature that
I did was shot on the the RT Alexa and
it's an amazing camera amazing d how it
looks it's incredible rich colors
dynamic range the whole bit the only
problem is it is expensive even if you
get a great deal it is going to run you
up and it is bulky it weighs a lot I
remember when you know we couldn't do
too many long takes my DP had to take a
break a lot I mean they can be depending
on what lenses mounts all of that they
can be you know 2530 pounds so what
you're having with the black magic is
again something that is very compact it
can work it's very I think user-friendly
and it's something that I absolutely
would recommend especially for any kind
of beginner first-time feature film
makers or DPS it's something that um I
think you should look into and hopefully
this helped